So we can measure performance as either latency or throughput.
Let's see now, how do we compare performance of two
different systems. So we want to be able to say
something like system X is N times faster than system
Y. And the way we usually refer to this statement
is that the speedup of X over Y is equal
to N. So we compute N as the speed of X divided by speed of Y, and now it starts
to matter whether we have latency as our
measure of speed or throughput. For throughput N
can be computed simply as the throughput of
X divided by throughput of Y, but for
latency, speed of X is not proportional to
the latency effects. The longer the latency, the
lower the speed. So what we do instead, is we divide the latency of Y by the
latency of X to get the speedup of X over Y.